This story is fun because we are traveling again,
and I never thought I'd say that.
I mean, it's just so crazy
and this story is so fun, okay.
So a lot of people are headed
to the romantic city of Venice, Italy.
That's right, they're riding gondolas,
strolling canals,
and apparently, shooting seagulls with a water gun.
What?
I know, okay, so the,
I heard this headline too
and I was like, "Wait a minute, what?"
'Cause I love seagulls.
Uh-huh?
I, I,
oh, yes, look, okay.
I have a chapter in the book I wrote
and the chapter's called "The Seagull".
Well, what's the chapter about?
I always covet other people's food.
(Ross laughs)
And I think that I might be as aggressive as a seagull.
I'm like, literally if you've,
does anyone have that syndrome, too?
Like the, oh, you ordered the other thing
and now I can't stop staring at that thing.
(audience laughs)
Uh-huh?
Or maybe I just wanna eat everything at the table.
And I just have a little, (mimics gull cry)
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
And since I was a kid
I have coveted everyone's food.
So they called me as a nickname, "The Seagull".
That is hilarious.
So Food & Wine reports
that Venice has an aggressive seagull problem.
And restaurants are providing guests
with tableside water guns
to squirt them.
Oh.
If they get too close to your old Spaghetti alle vongole.
(audience laughs)
(Ross chuckling)
They tried using an irritating sound
that humans couldn't hear, but they could.
Didn't work.
They tried unleashing falcons,
a bigger scarier bird.
Didn't work.
So they settled on Super Soakers.
This is kind of what I like about the seagulls though,
is they're scrappy and tenacious.
You can't just easily get rid of them.
I like that.
Yeah, but a squirt gun works.
So the thought, the question is, right.
If say, I had a plate of fries, right here,
and Drew was being like a Seagull, looking at my fries.
If I had a squirt gun, (laughs)
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
You wanna try it?
Just try it, Barrymore.
Okay, well, first of all.
Okay, oh, no!
(audience laughs)
First of all-
Try it.
(audience laughs)
Go, go, go.
(audience applauds)
It worked, it worked, it worked!
It worked!
(Ross laughs)
I got a whole mouthful. (mimics gull cry)
(bright music)